On March 3, 1876, one Mrs. Crouch was working
in her yard in Bath County, Kentucky, making
soap, when suddenly “meat which looked like
beef began to fall all around her. The sky
was perfectly clear at the time.” Falling
like large snowflakes and settling all around
the 5000 square foot yard, pieces of flesh
ranging in size from about two inches square
to four, dotted the ground and were even stuck
on the fences. When it first appeared, the
meat was said to be fresh, and, accordingly,
two unidentified (but brave) men even sampled
it. They claimed it tasted a bit gamey – like
mutton or even venison.
The story was published in the New York Times
on March 9th, and it caught the attention
of Leopold Brandeis who was able to get his
hands on a sample that had been preserved
in glycerine. After examining it, Brandeis
declared that the meat wasn’t a supernatural
phenomenon, or in fact, according to him,
even meat at all, but a substance called nostoc.
Nostoc has been known to scientists since
at least the 16th century when it was named
by Paracelsus. As with the Kentucky shower,
early on people believed that nostoc fell
from the sky in large chunks (or more rightly
blobs), and to medieval people it was known
as “witch’s jelly” and “troll’s
butter.”
Technically a genus of cyanobacteria that
live in colonies, it’s not clear when people
realized that nostoc does not, in fact, come
from the sky, but rather lives in the soil
and on moist surfaces. When dry, it is easy
to overlook nostoc as it appears as a dark,
flaky crust; however, after a rain, nostoc
will swell up into jelly-like masses. This
led people to think it fell from the sky with
rain, thus one of its nicknames “star jelly.”
Edible and said to taste like chicken or frog,
Brandeis was convinced that the Crouch’s
had nothing more than bacterial blobs on their
hands; however, although his theory accounted
for some of the details in the report, he
had overlooked two important points – eye
witness testimony claims they actually saw
the substance falling from the sky and it
was a clear day with no rain.
Further investigations were also conducted,
including one by histologist, Dr. A. Mead
Edwards, who also examined the chunks. He
concluded that the substance was definitely
not nostoc, but rather hunks of flesh. From
the tissue samples he had, it appeared to
come from the lungs of either a horse or a
human baby.
A third investigation by another histologist,
Dr. J.W.S. Arnold, confirmed the presence
of lung tissue, but also found animal cartilage.
Subsequent investigations confirmed both histologists’
findings and also revealed muscular tissue.
Finally, one man provided a theory that covered
all of the facts. L. D. Kastenbine, M.D.,
a Professor of Chemistry at the Louisville
College of Pharmacy, published an article
on the matter that same year in the Louisville
Medical Journal. Kastenbine concluded that
the best explanation was that supplied by
an old Ohio farmer: the meat had been vomited
by several vultures who were flying too high
to be seen (some varieties of vulture can
fly as high as 40,000 feet; for reference
Mount Everest is about 29,029 feet). Given
that the chunks fell from a great height,
they were scattered by the wind over a relatively
large area.
Both the turkey vulture, Cathartes aura, and
the black vulture, Coragyps atratus, are found
in that part of Kentucky, and both have been
observed projectile vomiting the contents
of their stomachs, sometimes in or just before
they take flight. They particular do this
in the presence of a predator, with the discarded
contents of their stomachs simultaneously
distracting the predator while also lightening
the vulture’s load for flight. When one
vomits, this also often induces others nearby
to vomit as well. As to why this particular
flock of vultures chose to vomit mid-flight
is anybody’s guess, but at least the theory
seems the most plausible explanation for this
bizarre phenomenon.
In November of 1970, whale meat rained from
the sky over a portion of Oregon. The cause
of this one is definitively known. The Oregon
Department of Transportation had the bright
idea of disposing of a dead beached sperm
whale by blowing it up with a half a ton of
dynamite. This did not work out as anticipated
and instead of disintegrating much of the
whale, instead huge flying, very dangerous,
chunks of whale were launched in all directions,
with one large chunk destroying a car some
1/4 of a mile away from the detonation point.
Frogs and toads have been reported falling
from the skies many times. In 1794, near Lalain,
France, 150 French soldiers were pelted with
hundreds of toads, many of which still retained
some of their tadpole tails.